let's go next to uh where do we want to
go how about
isaac from wyoming isaac you're on the
air
isaac from wyoming you're on the air
and isaac is gone that's too bad was
looking forward to speaking to a caller
from
wyoming let's go next to frumpus
from chicago frumpus here on the air
hang on david hey can you hear me
yes i'm right here okay hi david um
glad to hear you're doing good so i'm
wondering like with the
um with biden not going forward with the
public option
i'm wondering what the strategy is there
because i and a lot of other people
voted
for him um on that and i'm wondering why
he just decided to go with like
lowering these deductibles i think a
public option was even part of
obamacare's uh initial proposal before
it got cut so what's the strategy
i don't know i wish i could tell you and
you know it's not like i'm gonna be
uh uh defending things that i don't
think
should be defended i i don't i don't
know the answer to that
and is it part of some bigger strategy
is it part party
i don't know and um we we
you know i think that being four months
in as i said earlier only four months
into the presidency
i'm still sort of open and waiting and
seeing what the the full trajectory is
going to be but i
i just don't have an answer and you know
i'm not the defender of everything biden
does that's for sure yeah i got you i i
try to
i try to defend a lot of things biden
does but it's really hard now but like
yeah i was thinking at least
rhetorically he could go with like this
was obama's
thing and all this and so it's just
weird okay yeah that's it for me
um my girlfriend loves you by the way
love you
all right thanks guys appreciate it
thank you uh very nice nice phone call
okay why don't we go next to bret from
indiana brett you are on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
gosh i have to admit i'm actually super
nervous talking to you right now
you're doing great already i can tell
you're gonna be great so
um i'm not gonna lie i'm super
politically active and
i wish i could ask you 20 questions but
i know we're on a limited amount of time
right so i wanted to ask you how you
felt about this so
there's this debate of dc and puerto
rico statehood yep
for me dc there's no debate personally i
think it needs statehood at this point
i mean it's for another discussion but
puerto rico to me
is a little bit more complicated because
there's people who think
oh it's just colonizers wanting to just
add it to the united states
and one concern i have about it
is um basically there was a referendum
vote about whether they should
become independent or become a state and
it was 52 to 48 percent
right and i'm just do i'm just concerned
about that number because
my thing is i think that number's way
too low it's not overwhelming
it's not overwhelming and there are
people who say it should have been you
know it should have a 60
threshold or more i mean let's go
through it piece by piece
it is without question that the dc and
puerto rico situations are not the same
there's no question now
you can take the position that both
should be states
probably for slightly different reasons
but there's no question that the dc and
puerto rico situations are
different now one of the differences is
that
dc residents are much more over
overwhelmingly in support of being a
state than puerto rican residents are
and so what you're talking about is sort
of
the desire of the population and their
ability to to self-determine
i think that it's morally right to offer
both the opportunity to be states
and certainly the people that are there
uh can have
a say in that but i agree that they're
not the same situation
right and one more question
and then i'll just hit the road for you
so
i was wondering how
do you feel about education in this
country because i've always
argued strongly we should expand upon it
because
i'm in the national guard and um the
unit i go to once a month for drill
basically
it's in this small country town in
indiana and
i'm just going to put it plainly at the
high school there it looks like crap
yeah and like i've always argued there's
this inequality of education funding
you know small country towns they don't
get a lot of um
they don't get a lot of money from the
state compared to like big city schools
and then you know schools like you know
in places
like ha i don't want to call it the
ghetto that'd be rude i would call it
rather not very wealthy areas
they don't get as much more than a state
and i was just wondering how do you feel
we should expand upon education in this
country because
trump's presidency certainly made me
realize i feel like we have to work on
education
yeah so i mean at the educational system
this is such a big topic it has to be
completely rethought and reformed but
a couple of things are number one a lot
of this has to do
with how states are run and you have
states
that pride themselves on we have lower
no income tax or we have
very low property taxes or whatever and
then you get schools that are
equivalent to the amount of of low tax
that the states sort of brag about you
have state boards of education
including for example in texas where
they are just
destroying the curriculum and you you're
not
even getting a shot based on what these
boards of education
are are doing so one piece is at the
state level
federal education policy is a really
tough thing and
how do you do federal policy for a
country of 331 million people
it's a really difficult question to
answer and and a very complex one
but part of it is we've had long strings
of incompetent people in federal
education leadership i mean just look at
under trump
betsy devos she had no business being in
that position whatsoever
and so we you know we can talk about
specific reforms
but you've got to completely go back to
the drawing board with
the way that a lot of the where the
funding comes from
how funding is distributed what are the
metrics that are used for evaluating
schools and teachers what is done as a
result of those metrics the system is so
broken as you seem to be pointing out
yes i agree and you know there are
you know i speak um spanish and i'm
learning french and german
and like basically i went to madrid and
i was
really amazed as to how many you know
spanish people they spoke french or then
some of them spoke other languages
because they literally learned
since elementary school basically
languages no well the
the real if you look globally the
surprising thing is how
few people in the united states speak
two languages that's really
the surprising thing globally but to
many americans it's surprising to see
that so many people in other countries
do speak two languages it's completely
backwards brett
it is and yeah and so
i just i just really hope with biden's
presidency
something can get done because i'll say
one thing
i am pretty disgusted with joe manchin
and
kirsten cinema too right now because i
feel like they're a work
i feel like they're wolves in sheep's
clothing listen they're they're with us
on a lot of stuff
but they're not with us on enough stuff
that it's a big big concern brett
i appreciate the call thank you for your
service
yeah i appreciate it and by the way fun
fact i just drove past columbus indiana
where mike pence is from
there one they wanted to put up a statue
and then i just saw a sign where they
just said
vice president pence is from here fun
fact
all right brett thank you uh appreciate
that uh that
latest breaking news and hope to hear
from you again uh really close to a
perfect phone call my friends
that is all the time i have for calls
today apologies if i didn't get to you
and i will
hope to hear from you on the next one
one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online and you can
trust them they're the only vpn with an
always-on third-party audit
verifying that your internet activity is
not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with
10 devices logged in at the same time
you can try it for a week for just 99
cents and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman